How can the country overcome a crisis?
How can it reinvents itself,
change itself and transform.
These are two of the questions you have
asked us in the comments section here on
visual politic as well as a viewer.
I think we can say that the economy
usually evolves three cycles.
That is a growth phase is sooner or
laser always followed by a crisis and
then this crisis is followed again by a
new growth phase and so on and so
both.
For example,
since World War Two,
the United States has undergone 11
complete economic cycles.
That is both growth and crisis years.
Okay.
How has my friends things on always have
that simple?
Sometimes leaving a crisis is very,
very hard.
So much so that decades could go by so
much so that even a rich and prosperous
country can stop being a rich and
prosperous country because don't think
that this only effects emerging
countries,
not at all.
The richest countries can suffer this
type of deep crisis,
usually due to political reasons or
rather bad policies,
but he has to view our country can't
even escape these deepest of crises or
his hair on visual politic with,
for example,
the case of New Zealand's,
which after undergoing a very harsh
crisis,
managed to completely overturn the
situation.
Well,
in this video we're going to show you
another example and that would be the
example of Canada.
Yep.
You heard me right?
Did you know that Canada almost went
bankrupt?
Well,
if you didn't listen up Canada is one of
the richest freest and most prosperous
countries with the highest quality of
life on the planet.
It doesn't even matter what ranking we
use.
It can be the United Nations Hdi,
the corruption perception index of
Transparency International,
the Fraser Institute,
Human Freedom Index,
or the legatum prosperity index in all
of them.
Canada is always among the highest on
the list,
but this video isn't about rankings,
but before we move on,
I just do want to touch on one last one
very quickly.
See in the latest ranking of the best
countries prepared to buy us news
magazine and the Wharton School Canada
appears as the second best country to
live in in the world.
Pretty clear as we already saw it on
this channel,
that Canada,
dear viewer,
is very,
very popular right now.
How are the things in Canada once always
this happy?
There was a time in the 1960s and
especially in the 1970s where everything
was about to collapse.
Disaster.
Yes.
Can I do?
It was very similar to the United
States.
It was practically it's twin brother.
It had a very small governments.
The country was very decentralized and
taxes were very similar.
Of course,
the idea then was to compete to attract
investments and thus also people from
abroad,
immigrants.
However,
this all changed in the 1960s at that
time,
Canada sought to distance itself from
the United States and to try a new
political and economic model.
The great architects of this revolution
was Pierre Trudeau.
Yup.
That's the father of the current prime
minister,
Justin Trudeau.
We can forever spend more than we
obtained from tax.
Of course father and sons.
Politics aren't by no means the same.
It looks like just trudeau sets and he
did his homework,
but let's not straight from the subject
too much.
The fact is that just introduce father
govern Canada virtually uninterrupted
between 1968 in 1984 and the fact is
that throughout the 16 years in power,
the country changed a great deal.
Today I've seen you out once.
You do implement a new political model
in Canada,
which was a bit difference from
Washington's capitalism and somewhat
closer to Sylvia Moscow's collectivism
as against the invisible hand of Adam
Smith,
there has to be a visible hand of
politicians whose objective it is to
have the kind of society that is caring
and humane.
Pierre Trudeau in facts in international
politics.
One of the things the prime minister was
best known for was his close friendship
with Fidel Castro.
In any case,
the truth is that we could say that
Trudeau's father went a bit far,
he raised taxes a lot.
He increased public spending,
he nationalized companies.
And because he thought that all
international trade and investment was
bad due to competition,
he decided to set up barriers.
So speaking of barriers,
well who does that sound like?
President trump slap new tariffs on
imported washing machines and solar
panels.
If that wasn't enough,
he also made the central bank prints
banknotes despair to expand credit and
finance the government.
And well,
maybe this recipe is starting to sound a
bit familiar to you.
Well,
Venezuela's adding more zeroes to its
currency,
it releasing bills with larger
denominations.
Well,
the results of all of this,
Divya,
is that within a few years,
the deficits,
unemployment,
and inflation rates to put the whole
country up against the ropes.
So of course when in 1984 Pierre Trudeau
left office,
he did see with the lowest popularity
level for a Canadian prime minister in
decades,
only two out of every 10 Canadians still
supported him.
And it was at this time that Canadian
citizens have to make a really important
decision.
The chain in the September,
1984 elections,
the conservatives won an overwhelming
victory.
It was clear that the country could not
continue along Trudeau's path.
The new prime minister,
Brian Mulroney,
decided to reverse the situation and
began to strengthen ties with President
Ronald Reagan.
A new era had begun over the next 10
years.
The conservative government did many
things to improve Canada's economy.
For example,
lower taxes negotiated NAFTA,
the North American free trade agreements
that Unites Canada,
the u s and Mexico,
and following in Margaret Thatcher's
footsteps,
they launched an ambitious plan to
privatize large public companies such as
Air Canada and its Petro Canada.
Okay.
However,
he didn't do one thing,
the most difficult and some popular
action,
and that was controlling public
spending.
In 1990 the state held more than half of
the economy taxes.
We're still very high and there was a
huge public deficits and further public
debt rose rapidly.
Conservatives had taken the easiest
measures bus at the moment of truth.
They hadn't really shown much
commitments.
Therefore,
in the following 1993 elections,
Piatra jury is leftist Liberal Party won
the elections again.
This time it promising a true
revolution.
Could Pediatric Dose Party Save Canada
given it
backgrounds?
You cons and I,
this would have been very difficult to
imagine.
That's,
well,
everything was really different at this
time.
The new governments wanted to completely
change the country's model once and for
all and no,
they no longer wanted anything to do
with Moscow or the Soviet model is.
The main idea was that quality of life
wasn't only related to the economy,
it was dependent on it.
If they wanted to achieve on a quality
of life,
they needed to strengthen Canada's
economy and that's essentially what they
did,
especially under the minister of
Finance.
Paul Martin feet,
true change promoter.
Well,
the fact is that for the first few
years,
the leftist government launched a sharp
public spending cuts,
eliminated many unnecessary programs and
adjusted spending.
For example,
these strongly reduced military spending
and many companies subsidy
just two years in real times,
spending drops by 15% under the
principle,
which states that the state shouldn't do
things that companies can do better if
the government decided to continue with
the privatization plan in which they
went as far as privatizing the railways
and even the aviation management system.
Anne's no planes in Canada did not fall
out of the sky and no,
there haven't been more accidents than
they have been in other countries.
Indeed,
on the contrary,
Canada's aviation management system is
considered one of the best in the world.
The fact is that in just four years,
the situation was under control.
The governments had gone from having a
deficits to having a sub lists.
I mean,
check out this graphic.
Of course,
as you can imagine,
these measures,
they weren't easy.
But one thing that seemed to be very
clear to Canadians say much so if that's
in the 1997 elections,
the liberal leftist party won again by
promising still more careful and
government spending and on this occasion
fewer taxes as they said,
their role was to protect and give
opportunities to the most
disenfranchised and not to waste
everyone's money.
It all seems pretty sensible,
don't you think?
Well,
listen to Paul Martin's words in 2003 as
he reviewed that 10 years in power,
we have to build it.
21st century economy in Canada for
Canadians.
We succeeded in the last 10 years
because we did not deviate from our
course.
Balanced budgets,
uh,
continually dropping debt ratio,
lower taxes.
We must stay on that course.
We must be a government committed to
accountability of government that treats
taxpayers' money like it is your money,
Paul Martin.
This revolution was a real turning
points in Canada's history.
[inaudible]
to the country experienced in the 1980s
and especially in the 90s,
allowed for this country's situation to
change completely.
Canada went from being considered an
honorary member of the Third World by
the Wall Street Journal due to its
public debt problems to becoming the
most fashionable country in the world.
We'll potsy howdens only solve the
country's problems.
They had changed its model in the
following years up until today,
all political options opt for the
Canadian model.
Mind you,
Canada is no tax haven far from us
because they have understood that
companies need to be cared for and is
not punished.
Check this out.
Jobs
you had that rights.
If we take all taxes that companies pay
into accounts,
this country situation is actually very
advantageous.
In fact,
Canada is one of the few developed
countries that has been decreasing as
taxes for almost 20 years to make the
country more competitive and consider
for example,
how company taxes have evolved and this
policy has mostly favored.
The weakest salaries have grown a lot
and this is one of the countries that
receives the most immigrants and
employment rates are very high.
In addition,
if all of this weren't enough in recent
years,
Canada has also become a world civil
liberties champion as we saw her a
visual policy in a previous video.
And this Divya is how Canada managed to
escape its greatest crisis.
And by the way,
just as it happened in New Zealand and
Australia,
these reforms were carried out by
leftist parties.
But this isn't about left or right.
It's about understanding that a strong
competitive and globally open economy is
the best to improve everyone's quality
of life.
But having said that,
now it's your turn.
Do you think Canada is a good role
model?
Leave your answer in the comments below
as well as in this survey and I really
hope you enjoyed this video.
Please do hit that mic bus.
And if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday.
Also check it off.
Friends at the reconsider media
podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this
episode,
but we're not mine and as always,
thank you for watching.